Hello everyone.
Neal Browne with Bill Decker in the International Business Minute.
Bill, in America, we speak English, we also speak American,...
...which is sort of a lot of colloquialisms and figures of speech.
They don't understand that internationally.
No.
When you say, "This is going off the wall" and...
..."The person took the project belly up and we ran it up the flagpole"...
...and "We needed a ballpark figure" and "Let's dance with them"...
...and "Let's get into bed with that company"...
...no, most cultures do not understand what we mean by that,...
...and Americans make that mistake all the time.
All the time.
Sports analogies are very vague when we ask for a ballpark figure or we hit a home run...
...or we can't get to first base, these are all analogies that...
...unless you grew up here, you just don't understand what they mean.
And so, what does that mean for international business when people do that?
It shows, once again, cultural insensitivity.
It's almost like having bad grammar.
One I used to use all the time is "ain't."
Europeans hate the word "ain't."
It sounds cute, but "ain't" is not correct English,...
...so when we say "I ain't gonna do that!", it offends.
And that sinks your business chances potentially.
You ain't gonna get the deal.
Okay, good thing to know.
Neal Browne with Bill Decker in the International Business Minute.
We'll see you next time.